this is movie clips with our five films
were excited to see at the Melbourne
International Film Festival the
unspeakable act directed by Dan salad is
the story of Jackie Kimball a 70 year
old girl trying to deal with her
feelings of attraction for her own
brother the film is minimalist and
simply executed shot in HD with a small
budget in a review for film combat
Jonathan Robbins refers to the film as a
coming-of-age tale with an uncommon
twist he's the best person I know he's
the smartest and the most sensitive and
the most interesting and it's not
because he's my brother it's because
he's the best person there is all is
lost directed by JC Shandor this is JC
Chandor's follow-up to the very well
received margin call this follows a
sailor played by Robert Redford trying
to survive a storm all on a damaged
yacht according to Variety the film is
as close to pure existential cinema as
American filmmaking is likely to get
these days all his loss is an
emotionally resident one-man showcase
for Robert Redford
the turning an adaptation of Tim
Winton's collection of short stories
that spans three decades and 17
interconnected stories it will feature
an amalgamation of some of Australia's
most talented directors actors and
screenwriters the turning is a
three-hour event that represents one of
the most collaborative efforts in
Australian film history these final
hours the feature film debut of writer
and director Zack Hilditch follows the
story of James played by Nathan Phillips
as he heads to a party that is being
held only hours before the world is
about to end on his way there he saves
the life of Rhodes played by an gory
Rice who is trying to find her missing
father a film full of emotion and
redemption these final hours is based on
Hill ditches short film transmission it
felt like love the debut of
writer-director Eliza hittman follows
fourteen-year-old Lila played by juniper
sante as she pursues an older college
boy named Sammy played by Ronan
Rubinstein a raw detailed look at
teenage of motion CinemaScope referred
to this film as an affecting story of
female adolescents and unrequited
longing those were our five films that
were excited to see at this year's
Melbourne International Film Festival
comment below to let us know what you're
excited about thanks for watching
Oh
you